all right cookie
cookie uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally um originally i'm
from l.a
uh my family arkansas little rock well
you grew up in l.a you had both your
parents
know um i grew up with my mom
and then uh she moved me to vegas
when i was 13 and then i went to
with my father at 14 because my my
mother she was schizophrenic
and i just made the choice to move
my father
when it comes to
like my my my childhood
my dad when i was staying with him
it just he ended up doing drugs and
all types of stuff um
uh so how would you describe your
childhood then
i mean i had a good childhood up to the
point i turned
you know 14 when living with my dad i
had a normal childhood
it's just like uh my mom she had
mental issues and i just felt like i
wasn't
happy over there no more and at 14 what
kind of stuff started happening to you
with that with your dad his his friend
had raped me
so i ended up getting pregnant
and i had to get an abortion
uh he's in jail but so they caught him
yeah they caught him you were 14 yes
and where did your life go after that uh
i was in foster care i went through
the system but i ran away a lot
and at 15 16 i was in the streets too
and i was learning how to be a
prostitute
did you have somebody showing you the
way or no it was uh
just me trying to survive because i
didn't
like being in the foster care home it
was very disturbing
there was teenagers that were rolling up
weed with bible paper
it was crazy i just didn't want to be in
that predicament
but um i chose the life of prostitution
because i could survive this way
and i can um you know i didn't need much
but
a trick to get the uh rooms that i
needed
yeah it's easy solution to your to your
money problem
yeah it's hard to get a job in
yeah because you know you're trying to
you're trying to run away from the
system
and you're trying to survive so how far
do you go in school
i went to 11th grade and i um
stopped and
you you came to la at what point i came
to
when did i come to l.a yeah i came to
l.a
when i was 14
i've been in la ever since oh so when
you kind of left the foster home you
came out here mm-hmm oh i see
and do you work for the pimp no i don't
have a pit
and you're working uh south central
figueroa mostly
uh yes i work
um i work in south central wherever
right
yeah what's what are the ups and downs
of this life
oh the ups's your money is made
you know you can survive you can take
care of what you got to take care of
but the downs is you're risking your
life
and i've had incidents where
a guy has like pretended to be a trick
but he was a black guy
he he had tended windows he rolled his
his window down halfway
i couldn't see his whole face as soon as
i opened the door and i was getting in
and i saw he was black i tried to get
out the car he took off with me
while my foot was out of the car and he
dragged my um
leg with the street like my leg was
getting dragged
on the street and i had road rash on my
um
on my foot so yeah
you know it is
very risky you're risking your life
consistently
so i do still have injuries from that
but yeah
i mean how much do you think honestly
did you do
on a daily basis i say 500 i can make
500
in a daily basis you can make a thousand
on a good day
right do you have regulars or do you
just kind of
go buy who picks you up um i have
regulars so i don't really work the
street as much
so i tried my best to keep off the
streets that makes it safer
yeah have you ever had another job no
i i like sugar daddies i had just one
sugar daddy he paid me like 7
000. didn't even ask for sex he just
wanted to like
give me money in the envelope and meet
me at starbucks and talk to me and
you know get to know me yeah cause i cuz
like at the time
i was uh doing webcam girls services and
i met him
and he just wanted to like you know be a
sugar daddy
were you getting seven thousand dollar
envelopes yeah he would give me seven
thousand
dollars in the envelope how often would
that happen uh twice a week
he he was just like 14 000 a week yeah
he because he had money you know he was
an older guy
so he didn't mind he just wanted me to
like come
and spend time with him go shopping in
the mall with him
like a girlfriend how long did that last
um it lasted for two months
but then he was like you know moving out
of town
and he couldn't really see me that often
tomorrow
so but it happened for about two months
and i was able to afford my apartment
rent and i was able to get furniture
because of him
and everything you recall the first time
you did this
the first time i did this i was 15. this
is like
a year after i had the rape incident um
i was really running away from my foster
care
home so i went into the streets and i
met this girl and she was selling
herself
but she was young just like me she was
like 16 like a year older than me
but she she just told me like all you
got to do is get on the date
and um these guys they pay you for your
age
you just let them know how old you is
and they're gonna tip you
so
i would i just i would just you know
work like that
and guys would pay me for knowing how
young i am
you been arrested uh i've been arrested
but i haven't been convicted
so yeah i've been arrested plenty of
times
and are drugs are part of your life um
drugs no i don't do drugs
all i do is weed and i i consider to
herb i don't even consider that drug
it's legal here so do you have kids
no i have no children and you're 21 i'm
20 years old
20. okay and so
i mean do you enjoy this work do you
like i mean do you get depressed about
it i mean
is it you know what it's a self-esteem
boost in one way but it also
knocks yourself down it has became a way
for me to know my value
because at the end of the day like uh i
was feeling very
low self-esteem after getting pregnant
by a
older man so it's like
now i'm gonna make men treat me better
and they're not just gonna take my stuff
they're they're gonna pay for me
you know my mind switched at an early
age
so does this get you depressed sometimes
or no
uh i don't get depressed because at the
end of the day when i'm counting all the
money that i make
and i'm ready to go pay for my items i
don't get as much depression
no more because i'm like everybody has
something that they do that they may not
be proud of and nobody likes the work
that they do in a normal job either
that's true
so how many bankers right you know
you don't like getting up in the morning
and going to work
working nine to five for 12 an hour and
[ __ ] you don't like that
so are you saving money yeah i'm saving
my money
i'm putting my money up so when i have
the right
stuff to do with the money i will you
have any
dreams of what you'd like to do with
your life
yes i do my dreams is to become
like either a nurse one day
or to like
just i want to be a business woman
in general that's how i that's how i
look at myself as a business woman
and the the childhood you had especially
after 14 that is kind of
do you do you blame do you connect
you make a connection with that as to
why this became your lifestyle and
yeah i think it was because my my dad
has let me down as a father
so i i just feel like
a craving for male attention because you
know
i had a lack of a father protection in
my life that's why
i think i'd be doing this too
did you ever have you mentioned that one
bad experience does that happen
more than a few times or do you
get into situations with uh some of your
some of your clients oh uh yeah i mean
of course i've had
incidents where men have tried to hurt
me and like
or take their money back or you know
i've had crazy incidents
but uh at the end of the day i'm not
like
i'm not scared because i do protect
myself i i take
lengths to make sure i don't get killed
doing this
you know i always have i do a lot of
in-call
and stuff so i make sure that i'm in
control no matter what
so that a man can't just you know do
anything like choke me out or do
anything that's gonna
you know take my life away yeah
and and is going to vegas and working
the casinos a temptation for you
i mean what would be easier to get out
one day or or just
digging deeper and start doing things to
make even more money
it probably will be easier for me to
like
get out the situation once i've
once i've settled myself down in like a
nice home
where i know i don't have to go back to
the streets
i like that i know that i own this place
like i'm trying to own a house
so i don't ever have to worry about
anybody kicking me out or anything or
i have i like to have my i'm very
independent i like to have my own [ __ ]
once i get established i'm done with the
streets that's how i
am and i don't plan on doing this any
longer
like it's probably going to be next year
it's my last year
um i'm not i'm not continuing to stay in
it
so you're doing it purely for the money
yeah that's purely for the money
do you respect the guys that pick you up
or you oh i do not respect them
no yeah
what do what do you think people that
are not
in this lifestyle don't understand about
this line of work
they think that we're doing this because
we love being prostitutes it's not
because we love being prostitutes
it's because we have to survive just
like anybody else in the normal
working days we have to keep ourselves
some of us have kids some of us don't
you know we
we're just trying to survive and keep
ourselves above water just like
everybody else on a daily basis
you didn't have the role models and i
want people to understand that you
didn't have role models that kind of
led you into nursing or or anything else
that was more respectable
oh like do i have role models no i mean
you never had role models like your dad
was on drugs
yeah and then i didn't have no role
models yeah like i said i had 14 so
yeah my dad was on drugs so i didn't
have anybody telling me that this wasn't
the right way to go
either you know
so what do you what do you wish was
different about your childhood
but what would make the biggest impact
the biggest impact probably is if my mom
didn't
have the mental illness and she was able
to talk to me as a woman
but you know she's dealing with her own
mental illness
how can you stand for a child when you
can't fend for your own self right now
she has schizophrenia
so do you have a any siblings oh yeah i
do
and where are they um they're grown but
they're
running their own life i don't really
get in contact with them
or bother them with my problems in life
i'm very
like i said i'm very independent so
know i don't go asking for help or a
handout from my
family whatsoever you're doing it all on
your own
yeah um
uh i i when it comes to like any type of
pimp or anything there was this guy that
i was with
uh like a few months ago
but he just didn't give a [ __ ] about me
i say never have a pimp ever because
guys will like literally [ __ ] your
record up if you don't have a record
they will literally make you have a
record
they don't they're very reckless they
don't care about your life as a woman
what kind of guys pick you up are these
i mean how would you describe
your typical client um
you know what i would describe my
typical client it's usually the guys
that like
look for young women like they don't
know my age sometimes
so it would usually be a guy that's
looking for a young woman
that picked me up and these are thinking
that maybe i might be under 18.
these are professionals that have money
or these are
well i'm well when i'm on the street
it's you know
just guys looking for a young woman but
i worked as a stripper
when i was working as a stripper now
those are professionals
but when you talk about the street it's
kind of like just
guys who are married looking for an
affair
yeah yeah how would you compare working
a strip club to doing this
i say the strip club is better i have to
say the strip club is better
if you have action at being inside a
strip club i'll say take the strip club
over
prostitution because there's action at
the strip club in the back rooms and
stuff like that right
right but you know at the same time
you're in a safe environment where
nobody can kill you
because it's a workplace the streets are
just the streets are just you know free
you know you do whatever is gta 5 when
you out here
no there's no nobody watching your back
nobody
yeah has this changed the way you view
men you think
yeah it has changed my my way i view men
because i'm like i don't look at them as
a
relationship like love type i look at it
like business now
i don't really believe in love at this
point in my life like
it's like you can care about someone but
you know love
it's not gonna it's not gonna get me
nowhere right now
that's how i feel well what if that man
that you had a relationship with was
supportive and helped you achieve some
of your dreams
i mean i have people that that's what
i'm saying like there's a man in my life
that i
care about and i respect and i and i
like i really do care but i mean
it's not i just want to right now focus
on myself
i'm not really trying to look for a man
to love me if you care about me you
would just want me to do
the right thing in life and be
successful you wouldn't try to
you wouldn't try to change my mindset
you would want me to
continue to be going for my goal
that's all i'm saying
and do you do you have friends uh no
i don't have friends it's very lonely
for me right now
i don't have friends
and do you you stand back and just look
at what you're doing and go man this is
so
crazy and dangerous that you know
it it's not a typical life it's not
it isn't you almost you get accustomed
to it because you're doing it night
after night and it becomes like your
norm but it's it's definitely not the
norm for most people
it isn't the norm for most people i mean
i ain't gonna lie i got times where i
look in the mirror and i cry
i ain't gonna lie like i think every
prostitute had that moment
but i mean it's just
i see myself as a strong woman that can
overcome anything
you know if it's not this is going to be
another situation
or it could be motherhood you know
it's just as a woman i know that i got
to go through trials
and tribulations in my life no matter
what
how do you think is doing this for a
living has changed you you've been doing
it for
like five years now yeah
uh it has changed me because
i'm not scared i have no fear in me i
fear no man i fear no woman
i just i have no fear i don't feel deaf
either
because i faced it so much so i just
know it's something that's going to come
eventually
so i just hope it's not going to come
through being in the streets i just hope
it's a natural death for me
uh but i take precautions though to make
sure i don't die
that's that's what i do
i make sure i have weapons like you know
i make sure i have my defense my maids
my
taser on me i make sure i have my like i
don't i don't carry too much
but i carry enough to where like i would
not let nobody just
if you try to kill me it's not going to
be easy for you
yeah have you had to use those those
things yes i know how to use those
have you had to use them though oh yeah
i've had to use it yeah
like this this guy that i was talking
about because i was telling you like i
had this pimp that a couple of months
ago
that i was um with this guy like i had a
clean record
and he was like taking me to different
states and he ended up getting me
arrested
so you know it did put a little smud on
my record but i'm gonna get it cleared
but it's just like i want to let the
females know like
do not pay nobody do not pay no one
pay yourself you get you good guys
coming on to you with the
like as a as a boyfriend or as a manager
or something like that
but they're actually operating as a pimp
i get guys coming in like they want to
be my boyfriend but they're really on
some taking your money
yeah is is it hard to live this life
where everybody that you're interacting
with from the
pimps to the tricks to the to the other
girls on the street to everybody even
the cops
are doing something shady oh even the
cops are shady as i'm saying everybody
you're in
i mean your entire life exists where
everybody's
on the tape yeah that's why i say trust
no one yeah if you have nobody that's
really like got your back or would help
you
in a pure honest no the police are
really not your friend it's a hard way
to go with your life
yeah it is a hard way it is i think
i think that's maybe i mean the danger
is certainly a big thing but
just having nobody in your life that you
can trust that you really can rely on
must be very difficult yeah i mean
i've seen the police literally capture a
17 year old girl
and let her go right back on the blade
you know don't even care because at the
end of the day
they're not they're not here to protect
and serve they're here to get paid
so they don't care about if the miners
are out there
they know who's minors and they still
allow them to work
i honestly just want females to know
that the prostitution is not bad
but it's rigged and it's like people are
making it one way
but honestly we're we're trying to
keep ourselves safe while doing this if
y'all could make it legal
would be very appreciative because we
could be in a whole building doing this
without risk in our life and um
you try to make it seem like prostitutes
are all disease and all it is
but i have you know we're using condoms
we're using condoms
so when people try to make it seem like
you're selling your body you're going to
catch something out there
it's only if you're being a female
that's just dirty
but i'm not doing nothing without condom
so how do i period like
you know and we do get our checks up we
go to the clinic just like any normal
other female
and it's crazy because some of these
women what we call squares
they go [ __ ] on one night stands
but that's okay though and they don't
use condom
but that's normal for the most part i
think you guys are probably very
professional and
making sure that everyone's using a
condom and you're you're a businesswoman
and we check our
we go to the clintons we get our blood
drawn way more than a lot of people in
their own marriage
so so legalizing this would be a great
thing for the for the women right
yes because i believe that the miners
will be out of the game
and the the females that are legal they
can be
put in a nice brothel or they could be
put somewhere where they could be safe
and monitored
you know they don't have to worry about
a trick doing something to them
and we are very safe about having sex
a lot of these prostitutes they're using
condoms they're keeping safe
it's not no reason why as an adult they
shouldn't be able to legalize it
and a woman can have consensual sex with
the trick or the john
yeah the stigma of you being bad or
doing something illegal yes you don't
want these little
kids in the game you don't want these
kids walking the streets
legalize it so that the adults can be in
the game and they can still make their
money
legally you know you see that we're
struggling
and we're always getting found in
dumpsters we're getting found
all types of [ __ ] up ways because we
don't have no protection
it would be nice to have a security
guard just like in a strip club
it's nice to have security around them
yeah you wouldn't have the shady
characters that are just
yeah that's just out here just doing
some cereal ted bundy stuff
like i want that to stop yeah no kidding
you know i don't want to keep the kids
safe i don't want them in the game they
shouldn't have to
even be able to run outside their home
and go to figueroa
and what's the most important lesson you
think you've learned
what's the most important lesson in your
20 years
don't trust nobody in these streets
that's the most important your trust is
very important
then do not put your trust in anyone
if you really care and love yourself you
should not trust anyone
all right cookie thank you so much for
coming in and sharing your story and
i wish you the best of luck with
whatever you do in life and
i hope you stay safe okay thank you
thank you
you